hello guys my name is a Charo and
welcome to another Sparky dev vlog so
it's been a pretty busy week and I've
managed to get direct3d working so
that's kind of a headline of today but
there are also some other kind of
internal engine things that I've added
just for debugging and general system
kind of stuff so we're gonna kind of go
over them today and but particularly the
highlight is the test 2d which is our
kind of I used to be called test lab but
um that was back when we didn't have
three days and now if you look in
sandbox there are two dwell there are
three tests there's tests three-day test
2d and then then there's the deferred
test which doesn't actually work right
now because because I'm not working on
that right now
anyway test today and test three-day
test 3d still doesn't really work all
still doesn't work with DirectX there
are a few things that I'm missing well
the big the big thing that I'm missing
really there are two big things that I'm
missing the first one is writing the
actual pbi shader in HLSL that's one
thing I need to do then the other thing
is cube Maps right so there are no cube
textures there's no cube texture support
for DirectX if we look at texture cube
then it's largely unimplemented you can
see that it still got all the opengl
code kind of commented out whereas of
course the GL implementation for that is
is actually correct all right cool so
anyway test 2d on the other hand does
work so we're going to kind of focus on
that today if I go into sandbox that
looks really like Arabella let me just
close everything over here so we set the
rendering API the same way OpenGL and if
I just hit f5 to run test 2d you'll see
a few things that are probably new as
well let's just run that and we'll see
what happens so first of all we see our
scene with you know our font rendering
and just a few this is just a few
different tests as far as fonts go we've
got a
masks on this and we've got to surprise
one that just uses a color and I
probably show you guys a code and you
can see what I mean here we've got one
that uses a color and that is this
sprite over here right pink and there's
the other one that actually loads in a
texture and that's what the kind of
smiley face is texture filtering is set
to nearest which means that it's not
going to try and it's not gonna try and
do any kind of interpolation for the
texture it's just gonna find the nearest
pixel and snap to that basically so we
get this kind of pixelated look
basically what I mean is the texture is
like 8 by 8 but obviously we're
rendering and they're onto an area
that's a lot larger than 8 by 8 pixels
so instead of using linear interpolation
which would look like this we're doing
basically nearest which just looks for
the nearest neighboring pixel and snaps
to that does not do any kind of blurring
any kind of interpolation so so that
looks quite disgusting and if we go back
here to nearest then you can kind of see
what that looks like again then we've
got that and then we've also got a mask
on the whole thing which is why you see
this kind of first of all you see this
kind of almost like it looks almost
looks like lighting like there's a light
in the middle and there's some kind of
gradient but you also have this kind of
squiggle here that is in part of the
texture if we look at the actual texture
for that's right I got I was like oh
that anyway
good thing I I saw that I'll get back to
the later if we look at the resources
and we look at teh base of TB is the
actual texture that were looking at off
to zoom in okay
thanks for studio anyway we'll have to
zoom in what'd I just do I think I
zoomed in but it's gone now all right
this is fantastic
okay there we go how do I move this I
don't align I use this except it won't
let me
okay so anyway you can see that that's
what the texture looks like and then the
mask looks like I'm not sure why that's
not working by the way it's very weird
usually doesn't crash like that the mask
looks like this right so that's the mask
it's just like a squiggle and you can
see its got like a vignette on it which
while you get that kind of lighting
effect that gradient but that squiggle
is obviously what you're kind of seeing
so that's being that that's working
right because I feel like this is pretty
much all you have as far as Trudi goes
you know we have our we have like we
have sprites that are either
there's no Alpha sprite so that's
probably something I guess you could
kind of call yeah there's no alpha
sprite so we probably should do that
like partially transparent ones and to
make sure that we're kind of testing the
blending but this is a fairly reasonable
2d test because we've got a mask here
we've got to spray it with attachment
without a texture and we've got fonts
right and of course there you do use
blending and stuff you can see that the
hello glyphs will blend together because
like the cord for this script for
example obviously the piece is wider
than the eye and it's all blending
nicely if I if I didn't have blending
then it would look very different so
everything's looking pretty good that's
in OpenGL so if we go back to sandbox
and you switch over we switch over to
dress ready then come on you will see
the exact same result so I mean that's
the expected result right it should be
exactly the same right it should it
should not be you you shouldn't see
anything and like it directx and opengl
should look identical there's you
shouldn't be able to pick up pick out a
difference if you do then something's
wrong okay
so you can see that everything looks
exactly the same right the other thing I
added was up here now whatever you set
the window title to it doesn't also be
like a little pipe here and I'll tell
you what renderer you're currently using
that's kind of important as well because
I keep like I forget sometimes and also
it's good for debugging because if
someone sends me a screenshot then I can
I can see what renderer they're
currently using of them having to
specify anything a control tab of course
still brings out the debug menu and now
the debug menu is overlaid on top that's
also kind of a test of blending I guess
because you can see how that's overlaid
on top now which is good and what else I
think that's pretty much it right I
don't think I
I don't think of anything else to add in
terms of this
alright cool so that's graphing society
you can see the test hoodie now works
with the direct3d and OpenGL which is
very very exciting okay so the other
thing you might have noticed is the
three things you have this total
allocated thing total freed and we have
as part of the actual looks like part of
the debug layer we have an actual size
of my size and megabytes here and you
might be like what's all that what's
going on well these two are simply added
to the debug oh sorry to test today's
just labels right but basically what
I've done is I've added some form of
memory management not really eventually
Sparky will have proper allocators and
it'll properly probably allocate from
some kind of pool of memory so that we
don't have to deal with actual memory
allocations during runtime which would
be a you know during actual game time I
want to say obviously during loading and
stuff like that there's gonna be plenty
of allocations but during actual
rendering frames playing the game we
like the ideal perfect situation is to
have zero allocations of course that's
pretty much impossible but there are
ways to kind of mitigate that and you
can do that by you know having certain
you know like frame allocators and a
bunch of other kind of memory concepts
that we can talk about where you
actually already know like the memory
has been pre allocated and you're simply
kind of reusing it and you know exactly
where to get the memory from as well so
there's that kind of reduces a lot of
the performance implications that come
from dynamically allocating memory every
frame which is terrible so we don't want
to do that we are currently doing that
now if we do run this right and we will
switch to OpenGL here if we do run this
then you'll see that first of all we
have the turtle allocated which is the
total amount of memory that we've
allocated to date right so that is from
the beginning of Sparky starting to
where we are now that's the total amount
of memory that's been allocated okay
total freed is how much we've
Freed's right so this is great for
seeing memory leaks as well but this
thing up here is what we're currently
using now you might be like wow man
you're using like 92 megabytes
with yeah like this memory is actually
what our application is using not what
any other like dll's and nothing like
that right this includes Sparky core and
any anything that I guess anything that
statically links into Sparky core and
the actual game so sandbox that
application everything else that might
be in its own DLL has its own allocators
again we can't really keep track of that
memory we can obviously conceive it'll
studios doing it here but this is actual
game memory this is the one we care
about that's kind of just overhead that
we really can't do much about this is
actual memory and you can also see that
it is increasing every frame and you
might be like what's going on with that
and at the moment I'm pretty sure that
like we are freeing it obviously so
we're not leaking memory but it looks
like it it's probably vectors because
the standard vector the standard the the
standard template libraries vector class
likes to allocate memory liberally so it
is that's probably what's going on here
without me spending too much time
investigating it it's probably vector
but yeah I mean obviously they could be
fixed I'm not really too much too fussed
about that especially in 2d rendering
we're not allocating huge chunks of
memory either but just something to be
wary of obviously that this number for
one it makes should not increase I
believe we do allocate a little bit when
we open the debug menu and then we kind
of free it when we close it well totally
allocate is not going to go down but
that might I get such an insignificant
amount of a memory though that we're not
even seeing any change there all right
cool so anyway that's how that works if
you want to know how that actually works
well these are being fed in from
something called the memory manager and
vice terrain just converts like a 64-bit
integer of bytes into an actual nice
string so you can see how many megabytes
or kilobytes it is
or gigabytes the other thing actually
there's probably worth noting is when
you start up Sparky you'll see some
memory information I also got the
physical memory and in the virtual
memory of how much is available and then
total right so you say this is computer
16 gigs of memory and 10 is available so
that's kind of just system information
that I'll probably expand in the future
we also have the render the the renderer
information and we have a bunch of stuff
we haven't got warnings for large
allocations as well this is good for
detecting leaks as well and making sure
that we're not allocating stuff
keep in mind textures do get cleaned up
so if his texture was like a 500
megabyte texture as soon as that gets
sent to OpenGL gets deleted off the CPU
so or off main memory so that would
definitely go down if that was if that
were the case this texture is obviously
tiny because it's okay pixels and most
of the pixels are the same all right
anyway so that's how that works and then
if we look at what that actually does in
a file called memory dot H this is
basically the a bunch of overloads for
the new operator and then the delete
operator so whenever that operator gets
called it goes through this right it
actually allocates the memory of course
using malloc and in the case of new what
it does is that is it actually and all
of this stuff is really kind of
temporary you can see a lot of the codes
been copied and pasted ideally when I
have time I'll actually make it like an
allocated class and everything will go
through like an allocate function
instead of through directly through
malloc and all that stuff I just didn't
I just I just wanted to track memory
usage and I did this as fast as possible
so basically what we have here is when
we when we use a new operator when we
use the new operator we we request a
certain size in bytes of how much memory
we want we what what happens actually is
we allocate one by an extra not one by
an extra but four bytes extra well it
depends on what the size type is if it's
running a 64-bit this will be eight
bytes extra if it's 32-bit it'll be 4
bytes extra and what will actually
happen is we actually store at the
beginning of this block of memory we
store how much memory we actually
allocated now C does do something the
mouse
function does do something similar
because obviously when you call free it
needs to know how much memory to free so
it does do that automatically but that
is very compiler dependent so I'm doing
it myself
so basically what that means as you can
see here is that we basically copy the
size into that first kind of block of
bytes four bytes in this case because
it's point 32 and and that's it and then
we'll of course the pointer the pointer
to the memory we return is actually one
but ahead so when we come to delete it
and we all obviously increment stuff
like total a total allocated and current
used and then when we delete memory what
happens is we actually we we get the
beginning of the block of memory which
is the block - you know 4 bytes we
figure out the size by just you know
looking at that first size T which is
the first four bytes in the block and
then we can obviously see how much we
freed and decrease the currently used
memory and then free the entire memory
which is kind of the beginning of that
so that's how that works
eventually this will go through classes
instead of being copied and pasted at a
bunch of times obviously but that is how
that runs right now we also assert if we
try and if we try and only for arrays it
looks like we assert if we try and
allocate something very large and
usually that's good because occasionally
you'll try to allocate and I mean like
we look do try and allocate a block of
memory and in the size is like an
uninitialized variable and it'll be like
huge this is really easy for it to to to
detect because we should not be
allocating more than a gigabyte of
memory at a time anyway so that's how
that works cool so that's the whole
that's the whole memory allocation stuff
we've also got the memory manager class
which kind of does something similar
will doesn't do something similar but it
keeps track of all this stuff so we have
the system memory info which is what you
know for win32 it just queries
it just gets the global memory status
and fills that array out that'll be half
that'll have to be obviously implemented
per platform and then the memory starts
just keep track of that ok
pretty simple stuff and I don't think
there's anything else to note here
obviously we do some string formatting
stuff
and that's about it so that's the whole
memory thing and how it works again
right now it's really simple and right
now this isn't like a custom allocate or
anything you can state as you can see
it's still using malloc every single
time and it's not really doing anything
I mean it is custom a little bit in the
sense that is allocating an extra 4
bytes in 1/32 to actually make room for
that size and it is storing extra data
in that block of memory that you asked
for but it's not really like it's not
yeah well it's not really a customer
header it's just it's just kind of some
extra stuff added to malloc ok cool so
that's important because yeah we can see
how much memory were using now and
generally we now can control allocations
so anytime we allocate memory we can
stick code in there that we want to run
there's actually one more thing that's
useful for debugging that I kind of
skimmed over and that is you can
actually call new with a file on a line
and then of course that will end up
calling this new operator okay which
basically means that we now know what
file and what Lion well this is just
basically some extra kind of text that
we can put in here it can be anything
such as file online
uh-hum but basically this will just make
it so that if we do call new with that
since we do have a method for that it
means that we can we can see where that
memory was allocated so you can see a
lot of allocation at and this yeah okay
that's above a megabyte in fact onto
gigabyte here I want some well it's not
an assertion it's a warning but anyway
we can see what file in line we allocate
from it so instead of having to
obviously type in new with the file in
the line every time we can just make a
macro called SP new which is spark in
you and then that just calls it with
file in line automatically so that's why
you'll see and then an SP del is just
delete right you'll see and stuff like
whatever texture cube you'll see like SP
new everywhere and that just means that
we can kind of track those allocations a
bit better and that's basically the same
as new accepted of course inserts that
stuff automatically so anyway that's how
that works really useful for debugging
will be definitely
expanding on that more it's just that
I'm in the middle of graphics I really
want to be oh I really want to finish
this direct x and opengl stuff so I can
actually move on to developing the
engine because I feel like this we don't
really going forwards here we're just
kind of working on the pages we've got
now which is important but still it's a
bit annoying all right I think that's
all I wanted to cover the last thing I
want to cover which is why the star
appears free image is now actually in
the solution for Sparky so it used to be
that we just used the free image dot Lib
and we had to use a DLL now we are
statically linking free image which
means there is no DLL required and also
we've got the source code here the major
reason and the main the major motivation
that I wanted to include this stuff here
is because I want to take advantage of
some of the utilities that free image
had for example in free image you have
something like swap red-blue which is
actually part of the utilities package
which wasn't in the original DLL that I
found online so you could either compile
a DLL yourself and I thought well I'm
gonna have to compile for image again by
myself I might as well just included in
the project so I did that this was a bit
annoying to set up because there are a
lot of files
I didn't compile everything openexr
that's there is so much stuff in here
that I am just not compiling because
it's huge and it's a pain in the ass to
compile so I'm not doing that but anyway
we've got TIFF we got PNG we got all
that stuff if you look at plug-in age
and also means we can add plugins by the
way so in plugin dot h or rather in
plugins or c vp i guess you can see all
the plugins that we support so we are
supporting EXR raw we don't really need
those we are supporting all these though
so JPEG but a bitmap and you know PNG
look kind of stuff that you would expect
if tah-tah go
you have TGA right we're supporting all
that stuff and I was really all we need
gifts even a lot of stuff DDS as well
alright so anyway that's how that works
so it's now in here and free image is
quite large as well so there's a lot of
files there's a lot of extra files I
didn't include the open excel files in
the solution or anything but still I
think the solution count is going on by
about 400 for 300 or so files so there's
791 files now in the solution
and many of them are free image I think
most of them a free image has box2d free
image yeah lots of free image bit of
free type and real audio lib forbus
sandbox and then the rest is Sparky core
I believe it's quite a lot of sparkle
core as well it's about 250 files
alright anyway that's it that's what
I've done over the past week quite a lot
as you can see but hopefully this week
I'm actually going to photo last week
with me focusing on getting direct3d up
and running last day of love I believe
it wasn't running at all
so there's definitely an improvement but
yeah I'm going I'm going to focus on
getting now that I've got two deer
unning and when I focus on getting 3d
running with dro 3d and OpenGL and then
I'm going to go back and probably start
extending the engine next on my list I
think in actual engine work is probably
stuff like post effects I really want to
get them down so that I can start adding
stuff like bloom and screen space
effects like screen space ambient
occlusion and screen space reflections
to an extent probably what else is like
well yeah all the kind of postive
ex-post effect he effects to come they
come up HDR rendering is something that
I need to add as well that was actually
the next thing I want some and proper
turn mapping and getting it to maybe
adaptive exposure and a lot of kind of
stuff that have more effects based
because PBR is kind of done oh I also
need like good shadow support and light
map support like in the engine anyway a
lot of stuff lots of work adding some
kind of scripting language and I'm
trying to decide between Lua and c-sharp
at this point C sharp is quiet requires
quite a bit to actually get running but
I do prefer it to Lua so we'll see I
mean I'll probably end up adding a lower
just because it's easier but we'll see
alright guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed and you want to support Sparky
then you can head over to patreon calm
for slash the Cherno and become a patron
and that basically just yeah supports me
in my development of Sparky you get
access to some extra Sparky code that
not everyone will see as soon as I
finish direct3d so as soon as Sparky
runs correctly in like all of Sparky
including 3d Sparky pbl Sparky runs in
direct3d and OpenGL I'll be making an
official release on github
and I'll be pushing all the car to
github but if you want it before that
happens it should happen this month but
you do get access to a a more frequently
updated repository of Sparky code if
that is something you desire alright
guys have a good week and I'll see you
next time goodbye